Sekarang setelah kita membahas semua elemen VQE, mari kita
rangkum apa yang sudah kita pelajari dan lihat bagaimana komputer kuantum menjalankannya.
Kita mulai dengan reference state yang sudah kita pilih dengan cermat, parameterized circuit,
pilihan parameter awal, dan sebuah Hamiltonian.
Kita kirimkan semua ini ke komputer kuantum kita.
Sebelum Hamiltonian bisa dieksekusi pada ansatz state,
kita perlu melakukan pre-processing klasik pada circuit
agar bisa dibaca oleh hardware kuantum, dalam proses yang disebut transpilation.
Penting juga untuk memanfaatkan semaksimal mungkin
arsitektur qubit di hardware sungguhan untuk mendapatkan hasil terbaik.
Proses-proses ini sering ditangani secara otomatis sehingga kita tidak perlu
secara eksplisit mengetahui konektivitas qubit,
fidelitas gate, dan sebagainya.
Sekarang tugasnya adalah mengukur state yang dihasilkan
dan mengestimasi nilai ekspektasi, yang kemudian akan
dioptimalkan oleh optimizer klasik.
Pengukuran ini dilakukan dengan merotasi basis pengukuran
lalu menggabungkan hasil pengukuran untuk mendapatkan nilai ekspektasi.
Hasil yang telah diparameterisasi ini kemudian diumpankan
ke dalam optimizer klasik, yang menemukan parameter baru untuk state tersebut.
Kemudian prosesnya diulang.
Pre-processing klasik membuat parameterized circuit baru,
dan kita terapkan Hamiltonian yang sama seperti sebelumnya.
Perlu dicatat bahwa dalam seluruh proses VQE, kita hanya mengubah state
melalui parameter yang semakin lama semakin mendekati ground state.
Kita ulangi ini sampai kita puas dengan hasilnya.
Dan itulah semuanya.
Nama saya Victoria Lipinska, dan ini adalah kursus variational quantum eigensolver.